hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen hier heute meine damen und
herren zu einem neuen reaction video auf
meinem kanal ich hoffe euch geht es gut
mir geht es auch sehr gut danke der
nachfrage keine hat gefragt wir
reagieren heute gemeinsam auf das video
schnitzeljagd sahne ist mein leben das
video handelt mal wieder von dani sahne
und ist von family stories von rtl2 und
es geht darum es geht irgendwie um sie
und ein schnitzel sagen wir fangen ja da
seht ihr schon ganz normalen
wocheneinkauf von dani sammelt er
versteht mich nur aus sahne und amerikas
das obst und gemüse hat die dann auch
eingekauft hat obwohl auch allerdings
meine lieben freunde ich habe heute
endlich mal wieder nach einem jahr ein
video auf tik tok hochgeladen
wenn ihr das ganze video sehen wollt
dann schaut gerne bei mir dort oft
aktobe vorbei ich heiße dort laser
[Musik]
normalerweise nimmt man nicht den
einkaufswagen vom supermarkt mit nach
hause
natürlich muss das unternehmen ich mein
ich habe noch mehrere mieter im haus die
haben sich ja auch schon über den
gestank beschwert dir daher sage ich mal
auch nach oben
a
erst der vermieter von der dani und der
vermieter ist jetzt abgefuckt von der
dani weil sich auch seine anderen mieter
beschweren
die muss die wohnung gründlich sanieren
oder die strauße verschwinden wir wollen
mit rein was dabei rauskommt vermisst
dass man eine zeuge investieren schon
auch die china ja ziemlich aggressiv ans
männer standen da hab ich echt gedacht
müssten hier in halben stadt evakuiert
dass sie irgendwo in china erkenne luft
gegangen ist
der ist er ist es der freund von der da
nie so ein schweinestall wie hier habe
ich mein ganzes leben in meinen ganzen
so noch nicht gesehen
ja irgendwann recht ich meine dass
vermieter der wohnung der will natürlich
dass seine wohnung im normalen oder
beziehungsweise sogar gut gepflegten
zustand bleibt allerdings kann ein
bisschen freudig herangehen oder die
ganzen lebensmittelreste katzen größe
ist was ich wohl die katze mal hinten
dann brennt war doch die katze ein
und irgendwie ja denn wahrscheinlich
einbinden will
ich will ganz ehrlich diese folge family
stories bisher kommt ganz nah an den
hilf mir folgen aber wir schauen aber
wir sind ja noch nicht mal bei der
hälfte war ich mal den boden gemacht
hier zu bitten
ich komme ich klar ich bin im quadrat
kurzem dreieck jetzt pendelt sie da
ihren vermieter ein
das ist ja was schnell als jetzt ok bis
dann ist doch wir gehen
okay okay okay die laufen jetzt langsam
warum ich meine zu hängen bilder auch
immer aufgeführt zurück
jetzt genug das hast du jetzt vor nur
ist man heute seine stimme
ich weiß dass das alles nur gespielt ist
allerdings frage ich mich dennoch in
jeder hilfe folge beziehungsweise auch
wenn wir jetzt auf die stories reagieren
denn sie die regisseure und das
produktionsteam sich so etwas einfallen
lassen kann
das ist ja wahnsinn man muss auch sagen
dass das wahnsinnig gut geschauspielert
ist von dieser daniela und von dem
entsorgungs cooper nun so und ihr wisst
natürlich auch immer dass ich um gottes
willen niemanden beleidigen möchte mein
reactions ich weiß ist dass sie alles
nur gespielt ist ab ich finds trotzdem
so witzig und es ist ja
unterhaltungsfernsehen also kommen
schneit weiter den apparat was macht die
jetzt findet die sich da kohle an die
reucher tiere ihre bude da das hinaus in
wien das ist dann ist ja wie ich schon
gesagt wie kommt man auf so was ich habe
ein bisschen was in eurer kreativität
arbeite
[Musik]
naja und der burgen oder sie nimmt jetzt
ein süßes schüssel oder einen der ritt
leiden für rohstoffe
sie hatten einen normalen korrektur
jetzt ist mein gott zieht sie sie
attackiert jetzt ihr blüschen
ab gedacht hätte sich jetzt jeder jeden
moment in die hand gehabt dann hätte
beinahe wie es schmerze ja der typ ist
bestimmt nicht umgekippt
da ist dann auch keine lust mehr in
diesem chaos zu kochen und dann habe ich
hinter beschlossen mit ihr irgendwie
essen zu gehen
und jetzt geht es wahrscheinlich um
diese schnitzel sache wenn man es auf
ist was es werden noch keiner geschafft
[Musik]
daniela nimmt jetzt das schnitzel menü
war
da geht es darum dass man ein riesiges
xxl schnitzel bekommt für 19 euro 90 mit
pommes und wenn man das auf ist dann
bekommt man das geld zurück
beziehungsweise muster schnitzel nicht
bezahlt es hat bisher noch niemand
geschafft und daniela meint sie wird die
erste sein also ich bin gespannt
das ist ja
da ist ja schaut euch dann mit viel
daran und der salaten auf die trümmer
sind das für mein gott jetzt aber die
ketchup darauf geboten hier nutzen was
sind das mussten flutschen naja ich ja
ekelerregend pur auf einem ganz anderen
level trug
[Musik]
also ich es auch immer sehr gern ketchup
auf meinem feldsalat nach der es muss
etwas neidisch ist hoch gelobt oder kurz
auf die sich jetzt hier fünf fitness
tanz gewählt wird es ab 10 uhr anfangen
werden es uns richtig
ich weiß es nicht ich weiß nicht ob sie
schaffen wir das ist hier für mich jetzt
auch eine art wettkampf ich meine also
ich würde sagen sie schaffte save me
verwendest noch keiner geschafft hat er
jetzt auf sie zu schaffen
ich bin mal richtig mit gerade
was passiert jetzt sie nimmt jetzt die
sahne aus ihrer handtasche
[Musik]
wie bereits zu beginn der folge gesagt
meine lieben freunde ich möchte ich
überhaupt nicht die schauspielerin
hinter daniela oder hinter dem vermieter
oder hinter ihrem freunde da keine
ahnung was irgendwie im ansatz
beleidigen oder schlecht machen oder so
es geht mir hier lediglich um die
geschauspielert rolle über die ich mich
lustig mache ich glaube das wird ja auch
langsam aber ja schnitzel pommes und
ketchup
da würde ich auch noch mal zwischendurch
ein bisschen spröde alliance maul
sprühen ein paar sekunden später
was machst du jetzt gesagt oh mein gott
ist das jetzt mit der hand
halt die schnauze naqvi kinder sind
drosseln
[Musik]
nein
da habe ich gleich noch ein foto machen
von ihnen ja bis jetzt noch keiner
geschafft für mich gerne ein foto mit
zurück siegerehrung mit siegerehrung in
den 100 jahren über eine kamera am start
lächeln
[Musik]
lassen
ganz schwierige nummer diese dieser
heutige freue ich bin ich bin davor zu
sagen dass diese folge schlimmer war als
jegliche hilfe folgen
an welcher das heute geht es allerdings
auch beenden meine lieben freunde wenn
euch meine reaction noch dani seiner
schnitzeljagd gefallen hat das gerne
einen daumen hoch unter dem video
abonniert main kanal falls sie noch kein
teil der youtube seite wenn ihr wollt
dass ich öfter via actions hochladen und
falls ihr noch nichts vom neuen luca
shop.de lounge bekommen habt dann schaut
dort auch gerne vorbei es gibt noch
einige produkte die url kennt ihr glaube
ich alle lokalnews.de folgt mir gern auf
instagram daher sich laserdrucker auf
tik tok da hat sich auch laser luca mich
heute auf was neues hochgeladen und
[Musik]